[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Some of these
students may have just learned
how to use a tape
measure or a saw,
but they're quick
learners and hard workers
with an important mission--
to build homes for people
who desperately need them.
BRIAN TWOMEY: I was homeless
and living in a shelter-- church
basements.
Prior to that, I owned a home.
And I lost it to foreclosure.
And it was because
I got really sick.
And ended up in the hospital
and kind of lost everything.
SARAH SMITH: Nickelsville
is Seattle's largest
homeless encampment.
A homeless encampment
is essentially
a group of people who have
come together to provide safety
and community to one another.
And there are some rules that
go along with Nickelsville.
You can't be engaged in any kind
of substance use beyond coffee.
You really have to put
in community service
hours that contribute
to the life of the camp
while you're there.
NARRATOR: Sarah Smith
leads Saw Horse Revolution,
a youth-oriented construction
program currently focused
on building an eco
village at Nickelsville,
including a communal kitchen and
a series of personal shelters
that are efficient,
custom tiny homes.
SARAH SMITH: One
of the big things
we stress in the program
is that homelessness
is a point in time event.
It's not a result
of who you are.
So homelessness is something
that happens to you.
And I think we see that
reflected in Nickelsville.
People from all walks of
life-- families, single men,
single women-- all
can land in this camp.
NARRATOR: The program
is also a crash course
in carpentry and design
skills for the students
who experience what
it's like to design
a structure for a client.
SARAH SMITH: We actually go
to the homeless community
and check in and have a couple
different interviews with them
to see what they need.
NARRATOR: Materials
for the tiny homes
are sometimes donated or
re-used from architecture firms
or salvage stores.
SARAH SMITH: We actually
have a range of students.
A lot of them come from
their wood-shop class
where they're just
making a little box.
So they might know how
to use a tape measure,
but the concept
of framing a house
is something they can't
explore in school.
NGHI QUAN: [INAUDIBLE]
project, if you
were to drop me on
an island, I wouldn't
be able to build
anything, and probably
die off in like two days.
And then until now, if
you drop me on an island
I'll probably like make
a shelter for myself.
Make my own tools and stuff.
SARAH SMITH: This
house basically
is 10' by 9' on the
interior because we
sacrificed some of the floor
space for a nice covered porch.
There's going to be an interior
loft bed that essentially
has some closet
space underneath,
as well as shoe storage space.
There's a bench that
slips up and down
that has storage inside
of it that's lockable.
A tiny home is a
really natural fit
for people in groups
experiencing homelessness.
It has the aspect
of being a home.
You can build them really
quickly and at a low expense
without permitting
for the most part.
BRIAN TWOMEY: It's
transitionary.
It's a way for me to
be able to save money.
You know, I got a place to stay.
I can participate.
And be encampment, you know,
doing my security shifts.
And it's a way for
me to save money
so I can that first and
last deposit and get back
into an apartment.
It's great to be able to have
a key and a lock on, you know,
a door and have your
own space that's secure.
That's very important.
It's a big difference.
COLIN LAMB: It's given
me greater awareness
to the daily struggles
of a lot of people
who are homeless in Seattle.
And I can't wait to see
like somebody actually
living in that house
right there because I'll
know like, hey, I built that.
It's a great thing.
NARRATOR: To find out what
rights the homeless have,
watch this next episode
on Seeker Daily.
SUBJECT: In Rhode Island,
Connecticut, and Illinois,
some legislation is referred to
as a homeless bill of rights.
It attempts to
guarantee equal access
for all to medical care, free
speech, free movement, voting
rights, employment
opportunities, and privacy.
NARRATOR: Thanks
for watching, and be
sure to subscribe to Seeker
Stories for new videos
every week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]